(soft piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are, and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(soft electronic music)
- Humans eat meat more often,
and in greater quantities
than any other primate.
And as we've already heard
today twice, meat consumption
is seen by many as one
of the defining features
of our species.
And it's been linked to the evolution of
our large brains, bipedal
locomotion, pair bonding,
and other distinctly human traits.
So therefore, it's critically
important to understand
what caused this dramatic dietary shift.
So, to understand how and
why meat eating became
so prevalent in our
lineage, we need to know
something about the ancestral state.
In other words, we need
to make inferences about
the behavior of the last
common ancestor of humans
and our closest living relatives.
So I'm talking about this creature here.
That lived in Africa four
to eight million years ago.
So, as our closest living
relatives, and as specifically
as large-bodied, primarily
fruit-eating apes,
chimpanzees and bonobos provide clues
about the behavior of
this last common ancestor.
Of course, they're not
exact replicas or models
of the last common ancestor,
instead, they help us
to understand the ecological pressures
that this animal faced,
and in turn, can help us
understand what changed
in our lineage and why.
Both chimpanzees and bonobos eat meat.
But chimpanzees do so more often.
So, we know more about
the factors that affect
their hunting frequency, so that's why I'm
discussing chimpanzees today.
A little bit of background
on chimpanzee biology,
chimpanzee diet is dominated
by ripe fruit, figs,
like these here, are
particularly important.
The abundance and
distribution of ripe fruit
in chimp habitat affects
grouping and travel patterns
of the chimpanzees, which
as we will see, also affect
hunting behavior.
In addition to a largely
fruit-based diet, chimpanzees
also eat leaves,
specifically young leaves,
which are easier to digest,
and extract protein from.
The flowers and stems,
as well as invertebrates
like termites and ants, and at some sites,
they use tools to do so,
so here's a chimpanzee
at Gombe using a long blade
of grass to extract termites
from a termite mound.
So, it should come as no
surprise to this audience
now, that chimpanzees also eat meat.
But compared to humans, they
do so relatively rarely.
So, this is a, and it's
actually really surprising
to find that there are
relatively few published data
on the proportion of
diet spent eating meat.
So this is just a quick
and dirty breakdown
of diet from Gombe National Park, which is
where I work.
And as you can see, the time spent feeding
is dominated by ripe
fruit and leaves, and meat
makes up about 4.3% of feeding time.
Insects are about 3.2%.
Compared to Kanyawara, which
is Richard Rangam's site,
there, they spend less than
1% of their feeding time
eating meat, and at Mahale,
where they estimated it
in terms of grams per day,
it's only about 45 grams,
so very very different to
what we see among humans.
So, by far the most important prey species
for chimpanzees is the red colobus monkey.
These guys weigh from
eight to ten kilograms,
although at some sites, the
chimps target the young,
the infants and the juveniles, which are
obviously much smaller.
Red colobus are arboreal,
they live in trees.
They rarely come down to the ground.
And they live in large
groups, 50 or so individuals,
and they fiercely defend themselves
against the chimpanzee hunters.
So, when I say that they're the
most important prey species,
you can see why.
So, here are five major chimpanzee
long term research sites
and at all sites where red
colobus and chimpanzees
coexist, red colobus are the
most frequent prey species,
so you can see here, at Mahale,
Tai, Gombe and Kanyawara,
it's about 80% of the
prey taken are red colobus
monkeys, and at Ngogo,
at least until recently,
90% of the prey were red colobus, but this
has changed in recent years
because the chimpanzees
have decimated the red colobus population,
which we may hear about
later from David Watts.
So, which species make
up the other category,
the little gray bars at
the top on that last graph?
Well, to some extent,
other arboreal monkeys, so
from left to right, red tailed
guenons, black and white
colobus monkeys and blue monkeys.
And then also, they prey
upon small ungulates.
Infant bush pigs, at the bottom left.
Bush buck fawns, adult
duikers, which are small
forest antelopes, and then
small animals that hide
in tree holes, like this
galago here, and nestlings
and so on.
So hunts of the latter,
particularly the bottom row here,
don't really involve
pursuit in the same way
that hunts of arboreal
monkeys do, they're much more
of a quick grab as the
chimps come across them
as they're foraging.
Now, hunting frequency
varies considerably within
and between sites, ranging
from as few as two kills
per year in Budongo forest
in Uganda, to as many
as 136 per year, at Ngogo, also in uganda.
So, this variation
gives us the opportunity
to study the ecological
factors that affect
hunting decisions.
So clearly, much of this
variation is gonna be driven
by what prey species are
available in the habitat.
So, as we saw, red
colobus monkeys dominate
the prey profiles, at the
sites where they're present,
so if they're not
available, we're gonna see
lower rates of hunting overall, obviously.
So, we can see here,
at Fongoli and Budongo,
there are no red colobus
monkeys and their number
of prey per year killed
per year are quite low.
However, we see also, there's considerable
variation in the sites where
red colobus are present.
So there is additional
variation that's not explained
by the presence of red colobus monkeys.
So, it's not just gonna be the presence of
a particular species
that's important, it's also
gonna be important how
dense the population is,
how many there are in the habitat.
And this is a particular
challenge that we face,
particularly when it
comes to the cryptic prey.
So for example, these
galagos, they're small,
solitary, nocturnal
primates that are active
at night, and they nest in tree cavities
during the day, really
hard to get a good sense
of how many there are in the habitat.
So we're gonna hear in Jill
Pruetz's talk later today,
that these galagos are
eaten relatively frequently
at Fongoli, but this may simply be because
relative to other sites,
perhaps they're more common
there than they are elsewhere.
There's also considerable
variation within sites
as well, so I'll use Kibali National Park
as an example here.
Duiker, the small forest
antelope, they are frequently
seen at Ngogo, but only
rarely seen at Kanyawara,
which is the chimpanzee
community in the same
exact forest.
So, it's really challenging
to do so, but I think
we really need to have
some systematic comparison
of prey density, both within and between
study sites to fully
understand prey choice.
So, with that in mind, what
other factors are going
to affect hunting frequency?
So as a behavioral
ecologist, I think in terms
of the costs and the benefits of hunting,
the main costs are energy,
especially when hunting
arboreal monkeys, because
it takes a lot of effort
to climb trees quickly
and chase the monkeys.
Time is important, mean
hunt duration at Gombe,
Craig Stanford found, is about 28 minutes,
so this opportunity cost.
And then also injury,
from falling or from being
attacked by prey who clearly don't want
to be eaten.
The benefits, as we
heard about from Alyssa,
are clearer.
Meat is always gonna be beneficial.
Meat is a concentrated
source of easily accessible
macro and micronutrients.
However, for chimps, it
seems unlikely that meat is
essential to their diet,
given that some communities
rarely hunt, and even
among communities that
do hunt frequently, there
are some individuals
who rarely get meat.
So, they have other alternatives.
Presumably, the insect
diet that they have to get
some of these nutrients,
although it's less efficient
than getting it from meat.
So, therefore, we expect
chimpanzees to take advantage
of low cost opportunities to get meat.
They can afford to be
picky because they don't
require it to survive,
but when they can get it,
they'll take advantage of
those low cost opportunities.
So, I'm proposing that
variation in factors
that affect hunting costs
should affect hunting frequency.
So, what evidence do we
have that chimpanzees
are especially sensitive
to the costs of hunting?
First, theory predicts
that females should be more
risk-averse than males,
female reproductive success
is more closely tied to their
body condition, compared
to males, whose reproductive
success is determined
by the number of females
that they mate with.
So, the cost of wasted
effort, wasted effort
on failed hunting, should
be greater for females
than for males.
So this predicts, then, that
females should specialize
in prey, that are less costly to capture.
So indeed, at Gombe, females
capture over 60%, you can see
in the gray bar on the
right-hand side, 60%
of the sedentary, passive prey items, like
fledglings and bush buck fawns, things
that don't fight back and
don't run away, compared
to only about 10% of the arboreal monkeys,
which require a lot of effort to capture,
and they fight back.
In between, we have
terrestrial aggressive prey,
like bush buck, piglets,
who doesn't involve
climbing through the
trees, but they have very,
very angry moms, who are, you do not want
to mess with.
Okay, so at Gombe, females
specialize in these
sedentary, non-threatening prey.
Females do, as we saw,
sometimes hunt red colobus,
but when they're present at a hunt that's
already in progress, they're
less likely than males
to participate.
So this again suggests
that they're particularly
sensitive to the costs of hunting.
Also, there is less incentive
for females to hunt,
because when they're
successful, most often,
a male just comes and takes it away.
So instead, females are more likely to sit
and watch from below, and
then beg for meat from
successful male hunters.
At all sites, upon encountering
red colobus troupe,
a hunt is more likely to occur if there
are many adult male
chimpanzees present in a party.
The chimps have what we
call a fission fusion
social system, so if you
think of that oval as
one social group's range,
the entire social group
are never all together at
once, instead, they form
fluid sub-groups that change
in size and composition,
in relation to food and
female availability.
So, when I talk about the
number of male chimpanzees,
I'm talking about the
number of male chimpanzees
in one of those sub-groups,
and as I said, the likelihood
of a hunt occurring upon
encountering red colobus monkeys
is proportional to the
number of males present
in that party.
So, there is some debate
about why this is,
it could be that when
there are more males there,
there are more opportunities
to collaborate,
and to coordinate one's actions.
However, as my colleagues
and I have argued,
we think there's a simpler
alternative that group hunting
simply arises as the cumulative effect
of independent actions,
the more hunters there are,
the easier it is for one
individual to make a kill.
Either way, hunting costs are lower
as more individuals hunt.
So, large communities are
certainly going to have,
they're more likely to form these large
hunting parties,
contributing to the overall
hunting frequency, so remember, this chart
that I showed earlier, with variation
in hunting frequency, within
sites where red colobus
are present, so some of this variation
is certainly going to be
due to community size.
So, over the years when
these data were collected,
there were 150 to 200 chimpanzees
in the Ngogo community.
While Gombe, Mahale and
Kanyawara were all around 50.
Okay, so it certainly seems as though
the large population size at
Ngogo had an important affect
on hunting frequency.
Another factor is variation
in forest structure.
So, this is a high res satellite image
of part of Gombe, and you
can see just by looking,
that the density and
continuity of the forest canopy
varies considerably within the range of
a single chimpanzee community.
So we look in the valleys,
we see evergreen forest,
which looks like this,
it's a continuous canopy,
tall trees, it's really
costly for an individual
to hunt, lots of energy is
going to be spent climbing
and chasing, it's easier
for monkeys to escape,
so hunts might take longer,
and be less likely to succeed.
On the ridges, we see woodland habitat,
which are characterized
by short trees that
are widely spaced, so
it's easy to trap monkeys
in one single tree, less
energy spent catching them.
And as we expect from that,
we see that forest structure
does indeed have an effect
on both the probability
of hunting, in the darker
maroon bars, both at
Ngogo and Gombe.
And also, affects the
probability that a hunt succeeds,
as well.
Finally, overall diet quality.
Affects whether or not
chimpanzees will take on
the risk of hunting.
So for example, Richard
and I showed at Kanyawara
that hunting is more
frequent during periods when
overall high quality fruit is available.
And this result here, isn't
just because high quality
fruit enables the
formation of large parties
as it does at Gombe and
Ngogo, but once you take
that into account, we found that ...
The probability of a hunt
occurring was simply higher
after controlling for
group size during times
when there was high
quality fruit available.
So a party of six males,
you can see there, hunts
twice as often as a party of six males in
high quality fruit seasons,
hunts twice as often
as a party of six males in
low-quality fruit seasons.
We've argued that this
is because the costs
of a failed hunt are lower when there is
high quality food to fall back on.
So, to conclude, there
is considerable variation
in hunting frequency
within and between sites.
And this is because hunting
frequency is affected
by many ecological factors.
Having to do with the
prey, having to do with
the predators, and the
ecology of the site.
So, if we agree that it's
logical to conclude that
the last common ancestor
was faced with similar
ecological pressures, and
would therefore have exhibited
similar patterns, how then do we explain
the increase in hunting
in the homonid lineage?
So I suggest that the
first step might have been
an increase in low cost
opportunities to capture prey,
which could likely come as a
combination of many factors,
but I would argue that
certainly prey availability
and habitat were key factors.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
- There are actually no
chimpanzees in this image,
but I wanted to start
with it to remind you
as both of our previous
speakers very nicely
and eloquently told you,
humans are hyper-cooperative.
And in addition to the many ways in which
we depend on cooperation,
including for the construction
of auditoriums like this,
we also have what I think
is compelling evidence for an increase
in meat consumption from
the paleo-archeological
record, starting by about
two million years ago
at for example, this
site of Kanjera south,
several sites in Kanjera
in western Kenya, where
there's good evidence for hunting of small
to medium size antelope at
about two million years,
and then later at Olduvai and other sites
in east Africa, further
evidence for an increase
in meat consumption, including that image
in the upper right
there, of a recreation of
presumably homo erectus,
butchering a very large
animal, in that case, probably
scavenged, not hunted,
and then we have
chimpanzees, and chimpanzees
are along with bonobos, the
closest living relatives
of humans, and they eat
more meat than any other
non-human primates.
So, humans eat the most
meat of all primates,
but chimpanzees are our
second by quite a distance.
And when they hunt, and
succeed, when they have meat,
another resemblance to
humans is that they typically
engage in meat transfers.
And I use that term rather
than, they share meat,
or food sharing, because
we might want to reserve
sharing for peaceful
exchanges of meat, but meat
is not always ...
Individuals who don't
have meat don't always
get it peacefully.
There, this is, there are
various categorizations
of food transfers, and this is most of one
that Andreas Jaege and Karl von Scheich
used a few years ago, in
which they distinguished,
first of all,
forced transfers, that involve aggression,
so meat theft, or prey theft.
And then, a transfer that
happens, but it happens
passively, which is to say
that someone possesses meat
and someone else takes
some of it peacefully,
or maybe with some minor
aggression and resistance,
and some degree of
tolerance, varying degrees
of tolerance by the possessor,
and then there's what
they called reactive transfers,
that is, someone possesses
some meat, and someone
else requests or begs
for meat, and possessor
then makes it available
by something like that,
and then there's really
true, proactive sharing,
where someone has some meat
and of its own accord, offers
it to another individual.
And here, you see a sequence of an attempt
at getting a passive transfer.
This is an adult male chimpanzee at Ngogo
who is in possession
of about half an adult
female red colobus monkey,
and this is an adolescent male
who is hoping to get some of that meat,
and very patiently
sitting there like this,
afraid actually to try to
touch it, he did get meat
eventually, and in fact,
eventually the adult male
handed him a piece of meat.
Just to complicate matters
slightly, to simplify
matters slightly, I'm
just going to talk about
active and passive
sharing, so active sharing
or active transfers, the
possessor actually offers
meat to someone else,
and passive transfer,
someone has meat and allows someone else
to take some, but then I'll
complicate things slightly
by talking also about
what I call co-feeding,
where someone clearly controls some meat,
in this case, that male
controls half a blue monkey,
here, this male controls
an adult female red colobus
monkey, and there, that
male controls this yearling
red duiker, and as long
as they have firm control,
they are comfortable letting others
take what they want, so make
contact with the carcass
or with the meat package,
even feed from it
directly or tear pieces
off, so long as they don't
try to take the entire thing.
There have been a number,
I should say first of all,
that when it does come to the question of
why `do chimpanzees hunt,
I think as Ian explained,
they hunt because meat is good food.
But, because meat is
nutritionally so valuable
that then opens possibilities for meat
to take on social importance.
It may be that actually
transfers don't have
great social importance,
even though they involve
social interaction,
because what's going on
is that someone again,
has meat, they are trying
to eat it, and someone
else is trying to get some
of it and harassing them,
and the possessor can
improve usually his foraging efficiency,
his ability to use the
meat, by simply giving in
to the pressure and allowing someone else
to take some of it.
Also, there are diminishing
returns to someone
who has acquired the meat and perhaps has
a large amount of it, and
has already been feeding
on it for a while, when
someone else comes along
and asks for some of it.
It's also possible,
though, that meat assumes
an important role via
exchanges, either meat for meat,
so if one chimp has meat
now, today, and allows
someone else to have
some or even gives some,
to that other individual, then in return,
again, usually he will be able to get meat
in the future when they don't have some,
and the recipient does.
And it's also possible
that they exchange meat
for other things, notably,
grooming, between males
especially, and also coalitionary
support between males,
and then there is this
idea that males could
exchange meat for matings with females.
And in that case, transfers
are, to some extent,
actually contingent.
They're made selectively
to certain partners
and then received in return, selectively,
from certain partners.
These are not mutually
exclusive possibilities,
and in fact, based on what I see at Ngogo,
I would say that sometimes,
individuals get meat
by harassing whoever has
it, and the chimpanzee
being harassed might
try to avoid the beggar,
but eventually, just gives in, allows them
to have some meat, but
that does not rule out
the possibility that they
also use meat strategically
as a kind of social tool.
Clearly, the recipients of
meat get nutritional benefits
from obtaining it.
The question here is,
do the donors benefit
from allowing others to
have some of the meat,
and if it's a question of tolerated theft
or harassment, the benefit
might again simply be
that I have some meat, and by allowing
someone else to take it,
I can now utilize what
I have more efficiently,
because I don't have
to deal with the harassment, and possibly
the risk that if I don't
allow them to have it,
they'll try to steal all of it.
When it comes to possible social benefits,
again, the various
possibilities, reciprocity,
in meat transfers, so pairs of individuals
showing some balance in how often each can
get meat from the other
when the other has meat,
also ...
Male chimpanzees resemble
humans in that males
differ from almost all
other mammals, in that
males form very strong
social bonds with each other.
And they depend on each
other, they cooperate
in various ways, they also
spend extended periods
of time grooming with
each other and grooming
provides hygienic benefits, it also can
provide other health related benefits, via
its calming effects.
In addition, males
sometimes form coalitions
with each other, to back
each other up in contests
with third parties, and when they do that
often enough and reciprocally,
we call them allies,
so here, for example, you
see two former alpha males
at Ngogo who were each
other's allies for a long
period of time, initially,
he backed him up
when he was alpha male,
and then when things
had switched, he ...
Weya backed up Bartok,
who had replaced him
with one intervening male as alpha male.
So, males need social partners in contexts
other than hunts or meat
sharing opportunities,
and they need partners
for grooming, or certainly
can benefit from having partners
for coalitionary support,
and all the males
of a given community are
allies with each other
against outsiders, and relations between
neighboring chimpanzee
communities are intensely hostile,
which is a topic for another talk.
Not all potential partners
are equally valuable,
and we could expect that
male chimpanzee psychology
has been subject to
selection for tolerance
genderally, at least towards
familiar male chimpanzees,
and for higher tolerance
towards valuable partners,
and that would then provide
a basis for selectively
transferring meat to valuable partners.
It might sound a little
strange to talk about
male chimpanzees as being
tolerant, but again,
compared to males in other
mammals other than humans,
they are.
And this is an intriguing
indication that desperately
needs replication, that
there is something going on
socially, a paper by Rohan
Wittig and colleagues
that came out a few years
ago, in which they managed
to get a small number of urine samples
following meat transfer
events, and they did
assays for oxytocin,
which is a hormone that is
arguably involved in social
bonding, in reducing fear,
in potentially promoting
cooperation in various ways,
and they found that
oxytocin levels were higher
after meat transfers
than in other contexts
including even when
individuals had been grooming
with each other, or
than when they had been
feeding socially, that is,
in a group with other chimps,
but no transfers of food,
and the authors here
proposed that sharing
of food, and this was
not just meat, in fact, they had few cases
of meat transfers, which
is one reason why this
needs replication.
But, they proposed that sharing food
can provide a basis for cooperation.
Alternatively, but not
mutually exclusively,
it could be that we find
that close social partners
get food from each other relatively often,
but it's just because
they're more comfortable
with each other, so someone is more likely
to approach a meat possessor if he already
is a close social partner,
and then via harassing
the partner or tolerated
theft, gets some meat
from them.
If that's the case,
though, we wouldn't expect
to see variation in begging
success as a function
of partner value, nor would
we expect similar variation
in active sharing or in the amount of meat
that beggars inquire.
So, I'm going to take us
now to Ngogo for a while,
and Ngogo is one of several research sites
in Kibale National Park in western Uganda,
at three of which there are
chimpanzee research projects.
And in Kibale National Park,
there are seven species
of diurnal primates, not
all of them shown here,
and also small forest
antelope, like red duiker,
all of the animals in this image are prey
for chimpanzees, but as
Ian told you, mostly,
they prey on red colobus monkeys.
And this is results of
about 2,800 some bouts
of begging, that is one
individual trying to get meat
from someone else, and in most cases,
actually succeeding, in
great majority of cases,
although there's some
interesting variation,
for example, females are
less likely to get meat
from males, who are the major
possessors, than other males
are to get meat from them, and sometimes,
a transfer is made because
someone steals meat
from someone else, so theft.
What stands, and in most
cases, it's passive transfer,
so that's what's been reported
for other chimpanzee sites,
but one thing that
stands out here, is that
quite a few of the transfers
are active, that is,
someone offers meat to someone
else, and they could choose
not to do that.
And when I looked at the
results of all the attempts
to get meat and then put
that together with data
for a given study period
on how much grooming
the possessor got from
whoever was begging for meat,
it turned out that the
likelihood of getting meat
went up as the amount of grooming that
the possessor was receiving,
from, not at the moment,
but in general, from the beggar, went up.
So, more likely to transfer meat
to main grooming partners,
than to other males.
And this doesn't look so
dramatic, but I'll make
a more dramatic point in a moment.
Males are also more likely
to allow their allies
to have meat than they are males who
are not currently their allies.
Importantly, they're more
likely to give their allies meat
than they are to give other males meat.
So, this is the big difference
here, active sharing
much more common between
males who are allies
of each other, than
between males who aren't.
Also, males who groom
meat possessors a lot
are more likely to get large
shares of meat from them,
and a large share is a fuzzy definition,
but a small share would be a small piece
of a carcass, maybe just
a small scrap of meat.
A large share would be
something like an entire limb
or half an adult female
red colobus monkey,
and actually transfer of large shares
is quite common at Ngogo,
again, they go more often
to top grooming partners
than to other males
who are not top grooming
partners, and they particularly
go to allies, so again,
this difference here,
fairly close to half of
the bouts with transfers
between allies involved one
male getting a large share
of meat from the other,
and it's a considerable
amount in other bouts
also, but not so common
between males who are not allies.
Back to females, and there's
a lot more to be said
about females, I'll just briefly
cover this one hypothesis,
which has been called for better or worse,
meat for sex, and I don't
have time to go into
the details of the chimpanzee
mating system here,
it's quite complicated,
but most mating takes place
in situations where a female
is sexually receptive,
and is with multiple males,
and has an opportunity
to mate with most or all
of them, and it doesn't
make any difference whether a
female is sexually receptive
when it comes to the
odds that she gets meat
from males.
This is new data from
Ngogo, but it substantiates
what we've already said
about Ngogo, and what
Ian and colleagues have said about Gombe.
So, just to tie together
a few things here.
That, I think, makes it clear that data
from chimpanzees don't support arguments
that meat provisioning
formed part of homonid
male mating strategies, prior
to substantial increases
in hunting and meat
consumption and real dependence
on meat consumption for subsistence.
More importantly, though, I
think that chimpanzee hunting
and meat sharing, despite
all of the differences
from human, some of which,
again, we heard about
earlier today, do tell
us, and probably have
something important to tell
us about the psychology
of tolerance and
cooperation that underlies
obligatory hyper-cooperation in humans.
So, thank you.
(audience applauds)
- I do study chimpanzees
in a savanna, and I'd like
to tell you a little bit
more about that site,
because it does have a lot of importance
as far as the chimpanzees
hunting behavior goes,
and this map, I will show you, most of
the long-term chimpanzee
study sites operating
today, not all of them, but
these sites, most of them
here have been ongoing
for at least ten years,
and in some cases, and
in the case of Gombe
and Mahale, more than 50 years, and so
most of you are probably
familiar with Jane Goodall
and at least the person,
but Gombe is the site
that she helped establish
that Ian talked about.
I'm across the continent,
and I'm over in West Africa,
this is my site, the Fongoli study site.
And I chose this site
because it is in a savanna,
and we think that our lineage
evolutionarily speaking,
evolved in this type of
habitat, and so I'll show you
some images from the site.
My underlying questions
have to do with how these
chimpanzees differ from
chimpanzees living in forests,
like the chimps we've heard about before
at Ngogo and Gombe, and I
will cite Jim Moore here,
he's written a lot about using chimpanzees
as what we call a referential
model, and that is
comparing them to chimpanzees living in
a forested site, and
the assumption is that
the environment will have
effects on their behavior,
and I did think this going in, I had ideas
about what the differences
might be, and the chimps
kind of went their own way and showed me
a lot more differences,
including hunting and so
I'll talk to you about that today.
So I'm gonna talk about
three main questions.
And I focus on the types
of hunting, or aspects
of the Fongoli chimpanzees
hunting that you don't
necessarily see at
other sites, or that are
very rare.
And so, one of the things that we see here
commonly is that
chimpanzees hunt with tools,
and that's something that we use to define
our own species.
It has been seen literally
a handful of times
at another site, in
Tanzania, but at Fongoli,
chimpanzees do this quite
frequently, so we've seen
hundreds of cases now,
and I'll talk to you
more about that.
So, one of the questions
that I'll touch on is why
hunt with tools in this
particular habitat?
Something else that is not really common
at other chimpanzee
sites, is that in fact,
regarding this particular type of hunting,
females are more frequently
going to be those
hunting with tools, compared
to males, and as we heard,
that's just not the case, in most other
chimpanzee study sites, so
I'll talk more about that.
And then to follow up, with David's talk,
I will talk about meat sharing, or, I use
the word sharing, and I'll talk about how
I define that, but I'll specifically talk
about how females dole out meat.
And then finally, I'll
come back to this idea
about using chimpanzees as
a model, and what perhaps,
the Fongoli chimpanzees
I study can help us
say or think about in
terms of the evolution
of early homonid or bipedal ape hunting.
So, these are some images
from my study site,
the Fongoli study site is
one of the hottest, driest,
and most vegetatively open
sites that you see today.
Where chimpanzees have
actually been habituated to
human presence, so this
took us quite a long time,
it took us four years, I started in 2001.
And we habituated males to our presence
by 2005, but I wasn't able to identify
all the chimpanzees in
the group until 2006.
That's when we identified all the females.
This is a view of my
pretty fancy camp there.
And hopefully, that gives you some idea
of the vegetation, so
it's a woodland savanna,
the dominant understory is grass.
Thus, savanna.
But you do have a large
proportion of the habitat
as woodlands, over half of
the habitat is woodland,
and only a very small
portion is forest, about
3% of the habitat is
forest, and this is where
you find your water sources.
This is really the chimpanzees'
most limiting resource
at Fongoli, is water.
Temperatures are incredibly
hot, really hot for me,
even hot for chimps.
So right now, we're, we
have the month of March
in Senegal is almost approaching the peak
of the dry season, so
temperatures are regularly
over 100 degrees.
They may get up to 115 or so.
During the rainy season, or
at least at the beginning
of the rainy season, you
find some relief, because
the trees will put out
leaves again, they lose
all their trees during the dry season.
You have this lag, you
have hot temperatures,
and then you have this
high humidity, which
is really fun and so, literally
the heat index in June
is around 120, 125.
And that's when I take students out.
(audience laughs)
So, a little bit about
the Fongoli study group.
Within this particular
habitat, they have a very large
home range, 110
kilometers, which is one of
the largest, if not the
largest so far described.
The community size is relatively small,
it's not the smallest
chimpanzee community studied,
but it's on the small
size, around 35 chimps,
and importantly, we have a
sex ratio that is sort of
the opposite of what
you see at other sites,
so we have more males than females,
that's usually not the case.
And the data that I'm
gonna talk about today
stem from 2005 through to 2017.
One other thing I'll say
about adult males versus
adult females, is because of the fact that
when I first got to Fongoli, I heard that
even though chimpanzees
are not eaten at the site,
and this is not within
a national park, this
is outside of a national
park, so you do have villages
in the area, anthropogenic
or human disturbance
accounts for about 5% of the habitat.
You do have chimpanzees
living alongside people,
they're not habituated to
them, they're habituated
to us, so we're okay,
but other people are not.
But in rare cases, you do have people that
will try to hunt a
chimpanzee in order to get
a female's infant for the pet trade.
And we had that happen
one time in 17 years,
and because of that,
I focus on adult males
as my focal subjects.
The Fongoli community is often
together as one large group,
so I can collect data
on females, but they are
more timid when they're by themselves
and I don't try to follow them when
they're by themselves.
So I think I know a lot
about what is going on
with males, and I know some about what is
going on with females,
but perhaps not as much.
So this pie chart gives you
an idea of the prey species
consumed by Fongoli
chimpanzees, both by males
and by females.
And as Ian pointed out,
there are no colobus monkeys
in this particular
habitat, so it is a savanna
woodland habitat, colobus
monkeys don't occur here,
forest guenons like red tail monkeys
or other colobus monkeys, blue monkeys,
do not occur here.
Instead, you have savanna
species, like baboons,
patas monkeys, vervets,
you have mongooses,
bushbucks, things like this, and then
on the very lower right,
you see the adorable
little bush baby, and Ian
introduced the galago as well.
The galago is actually
the main prey species
of Fongoli chimpanzees.
Both males and females,
and this is the animal
that they hunt with
tools, and I'll actually
hopefully show you some video of that
and talk more about that.
So, the prey profile, if
you wanna call it that,
really reflects the
savanna type of habitat,
and it does also support,
as Ian pointed out,
or talked about, what is
called a risk-averse strategy.
So, I'm just gonna show you some video,
and try to narrate it here.
So this is tool assisted
hunting, what this image
is gonna show you, is
an adult female that's,
if you can't tell, that's
Farafa, she's an older female,
we estimate her age to be around 40,
she's one of the top female
hunters in the group.
So, she is trying to get at these adorable
little bush babies that
try to sleep in cavities
during the day, until this rude chimpanzee
comes with a tool.
That's an adult male,
that's Jumpkin, and he goes
about it a little bit differently.
(audience laughs)
And so, even though
females hunt with tools
more than expected, I'll
talk a little bit more
about that next.
Males do exhibit this type
of hunting behavior as well.
(audience laughs)
I have to say, he's
usually better than that.
(audience laughs)
They just caught him on a bad day.
We'll let Jumpkin try one more time.
(audience laughs)
If you didn't guess, he wasn't successful.
In this particular bout.
So, we're looking at a lot of
different aspects of this ...
(audience laughs)
I almost feel bad showing that.
We're looking at a lot
of different aspects
of this particular
behavior, and so this is
a juvenile female, Vivian,
that was her mother
that was hunting, and the juveniles start
this behavior when they're
about two years of age,
when they're still infants, and nursing,
but they don't learn really the proper ...
Tool length and that sort of thing, until
they get to be about four, so she gets
a little frustrated too.
(audience laughs)
Alright, enough fun, I guess.
So, in terms of our results so far ...
I apologize, because
in your abstract, I put
over 500, I was sure that
we would hit the 500 mark
this year, 499, I just can't believe it.
(audience laughs)
But we have 499 hunting
records, those aren't
all successes, and that's
including adults and immatures,
we've only seen adolescent
and adult individuals
successful in this type
of hunting behavior.
Like I said, infants begin to exhibit it,
and they do really good,
as far as making the tool,
but they don't make a proper tool until
they get to be a juvenile.
So, we see about 32 hunts
per year on average,
when you take into account
that there are some days
that we can't be there,
the river's too high
or someone's sick, we think
that they probably hunt
at least 50 times a year.
And again, most recent
analyses suggest that females
do hunt significantly more
than expected, with tools.
Even though males also hunt.
And we did analyses taking
into account not only
the membership and the
community as a whole,
but also the membership in
so-called hunting parties,
or parties that the chimpanzees
are in on those days.
So, I wanna talk a little
bit more about just
the hunters themselves, and
this is a lot of color there,
but I wanted to show
you the top ten hunters
at Fongoli, and also, the
different types of foods
or prey that they hunt,
and so you have two females
that are actually among
the top ten hunters
at Fongoli.
Interestingly, I think, is
that both of those females
are very high ranking, so
Tumbo there is currently
our alpha female, based
on these very stylized
pant grunt records.
Sorry, vocalizations,
and we keep records of
these vocalizations, where
a subordinate individual
will pant grunt to a dominant individual.
And Tumbo actually overtook
that alpha position
from Farafa there.
About two years ago.
And so, females actually do
hunt some in this community,
or at least, enough to be considered among
the top ten Fongoli
hunters, and also, I'd like
to point out that we
have a tie right now for
the very top hunter, and
one is the alpha male,
that's David.
He is tied for the top
hunting position with Siberut,
and some of you will be
happy to know that Siberut,
who is pictured there, is
not only the oldest hunter
in the group, he's the
oldest male, but he's
also the lowest ranking male as well.
And then, if you look at
female hunting behavior
in general, females,
almost all females hunt,
and almost all males hunt
as well, so they hunt
about what you would expect,
or at least their participation
in hunting overall is
what you would expect,
based on their membership
in the Fongoli community.
I wanted to talk a little
bit about Fongoli hunting ...
In the context of female
hunting across study sites,
so Ian talked about that
some, and I've used data from
his work and others, to look
at Fongoli female hunting,
and in fact, there are
females elsewhere that also
engage in quite a bit of hunting, in fact,
females at Mahale hunt a
little more than females
at Fongoli, if you look at Fongoli female
hunting behavior overall,
and then when you look
at tool use, you see that Fongoli females
do hunt quite a bit, almost
half of the tool-assisted
hunting at Fongoli is
by females, and again,
remember that we have
fewer females at Fongoli,
we don't follow females
systematically like we do males,
and so one question as
to why females hunt,
is basically as David started out with,
it, you know, it's probably no surprise
that chimps gain a lot of
nutrition from hunting,
but I think perhaps the
more interesting question
is why females don't
hunt more at other sites.
And Ian talked about some
of these issues as well,
that I'll pursue right now.
And so, if you looked
at, for example, theft.
There's not a lot of theft at Fongoli,
so when I use the word
share, I'm referring
to basically, the last
three categories, I think,
that David talked about,
so active food transfer,
but not theft.
Right, and passive food
transfer, etc., so I consider
theft to be a different
category, and at Fongoli,
we have very little theft.
The only theft we've seen involves
two different alpha males.
So very little theft.
Whereas at other sites,
you do have quite a bit
of theft, and so, I believe as Ian said,
females don't have incentive
to hunt at some sites
at Fongoli, there definitely is incentive,
and not only females, but
this is a little video
of, again, that lower ranking male, so out
of 13 males, he's number
13, he's the oldest male,
that's Siberut, so he's
walking by a number
of adult males with
his bush buck fawn that
he's captured, and no
one makes any attempt
to take it from him.
He had actually been eating on that fawn
for over an hour and he
had a number of individuals
sitting around, basically
begging, he didn't
share with them, and as he moves off,
you'll see that there's another older male
that will follow him, and
this is his ally Bandit.
Where's Bandit?
There he is.
Calmly following his buddy, Siberut out,
and so, he did end up sharing with Bandit,
so not only do you see some
sort of concept of, well,
I hate to say concept of ownership,
but you see tolerance, so
tolerance of possession
of prey by dominant males of
these low ranking individuals,
females and also lower ranking males,
so I think that at
Fongoli, you actually have
the incentive to hunt,
it's one of the reasons
that you see so much hunting, at least
tool assisted hunting, in females.
I wanted to show a slightly different way,
so these are the same top
ten hunters, but rather than
being expressed in the number of prey that
they've brought in, this
is the number of kilograms,
or estimated kilograms of meat, right,
and so you see that David has jumped up
to number one position there.
It depends on what you
hunt, and almost everybody
hunts bush babies,
except K.L., we've never
seen him capture a bush
baby, but what's interesting
is you see that the
third top hunter there,
at least in terms of prey
captures, Lupin has fallen
quite low, because he
does seem to specialize
on bush babies.
So the females really
didn't change positions
at all, they're still in
the top ten, but you do
see a lot of variation,
so that's something that
we're looking at now,
and so, I wanted to talk
just a little bit about
what females can provide
in terms of transfer or sharing.
And we, so far this is still preliminary
to some degree, we've looked
at sharing or food transfer
by females, and again,
I'm considering David's
categories of active
transfer, passive transfer,
and scrounging, but tolerated scrounging,
and I'm not considering
theft in this category.
Females actually shared
with other individuals,
more often, they did with their offspring,
so that's something we're
exploring right now.
And basically, I would argue that females,
as Rebecca has pointed
out, should be considered
as well, and finally, I'll
just move on to my last slide,
and leave you with a couple of thoughts.
First of all, I think Travis Pickering
said it probably better than
I can, so he actually thinks
that if you think about
the tool assisted hunting
at Fongoli, it perhaps can tell us
more about some of the
early homonid hunting
that went on compared to
the emotionally charged
hunting of chimpanzees, as he puts it.
And I'll just end up
by saying, echoing what
Rebecca has said as well
about female humans,
is that just now, and I
think Richard mentioned this
as well, we're beginning
to understand more about
female chimpanzee hunting,
and that they also
play a part in this scenario.
So thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat electronic music)